congressman kim buck joins us now
congressman great to see you this
morning
uh let's talk about that moment
treason you went directly at mayorcus
and repeated something you said you're
hearing from your constituents i'm
curious
is that a specific term in your mind is
that something that is uh narrowly
tailored in your indictment of what
mayorkas has done in his job
i think my constituents understand that
when an nfl coach doesn't win a game for
13 seasons uh five seasons three seasons
they're gonna lose their job uh
secretary marcus should lose his job
what he's done at the border is a
complete and total failure he has
dismantled the effective policies from
president trump and the result is that
we have chaos at the border we have
record numbers of illegal immigrants
coming into this country we have
thousands of pounds of
fentanyl coming into this country we
have record numbers of americans dying
from fentanyl overdose number one
cause of death between uh
ages 18 and 45 fentanyl overdose that's
disgraceful and and this secretary acts
as if he has been successful on the
border what i asked him to do was to
explain to my constituents why he is not
acting intentionally
when he is opening our southern border
congressman uh i want to
i want to actually come back to your
analogy in just one moment but let's
follow up on this this line of
questioning about about the impeachment
and then or treason and then what it
could mean in terms of heard the the
concept of impeachment brought up i've
honestly never thought about this when
it comes to cabinet members how does
that process work is that something that
can be done in removing you know an
officer under the executive branch
it can be a a
officer can be impeached by congress
obviously the the house impeaches and
the the senate convicts uh and and i
don't know that i have i can remember
a more deserving
uh
uh
candidate for impeachment than secretary
marcus what he has done is intentional
you know he has these uh private
organizations that the the federal
government is paying using taxpayer
dollars to pay that actually recruit
allegedly recruit and train
illegal immigrants to come into this
country and say the right things right
if that's happening
along with opening our southern border
along with his statement that he
believes we should have amnesty for
people who have come into this country
illegally then i i believe that what he
has done is is certainly deserving of
further scrutiny yeah and congressman
i'm pressing you on specificity here
when it comes to this term because what
we're talking about ultimately is
accountability i think there's any doubt
what you're saying is true that the oath
of office has been abdicated and it has
been done so intentionally so now at the
end of our conversation then let's push
for that accountability that i'm kind of
narrowly tailoring you into and i want
to go back to your analogy the problem
is when a football coach loses games he
gets fired the head coach as you
mentioned
is mayorkas the head football coach on
this intentional policy or is he simply
the offensive coordinator or the
quarterback coach implementing a policy
coming down from a head coach that we
would assume is the president of the
united states
well i think he's clearly acting at the
direction and at the behest of the
president united states but i also think
that he has to accept responsibility and
what he's done
specifically
president biden asked him to look at the
remain in mexico policy he left it up to
secretary marcus to decide to remove
that policy so uh secretary marcus was
given certain discretion and and
exercised that discretion in a way that
that is uh
harmful to the united states should
president biden be held accountable also
absolutely
yeah yeah absolutely um so i guess what
we're talking about is the beginning of
accountability um and so we look forward
to seeing where this goes congressman
ken buck thank you for
sharing with us your intentions we hope
going forward thank you thank you